very much
new details this afternoon in the
wisconsin parade tragedy which killed
five people waukesha police now plan to
pursue intentional homicide charges
against the man involved this is some
witness video of the chase
the name of the suspect is daryl brooks
and eight news now has confirmed he's a
registered sex offender here in nevada
nancy chen reports
cbs news has learned the suspect in the
deadly suv incident at a holiday parade
in waukesha wisconsin has been
identified as daryl brooks a law
enforcement official tells cbs news
preliminary information indicates he was
fleeing another crime at the time
turning the celebration to horror in an
instant
at one point the vehicle narrowly missed
hitting a small child as it tore through
the parade route bystanders hurried to
help the injured 18 kids were brought to
our children's emergency department
ranging from ages 3 to 16 years of age
which include three sets of siblings
injuries range from facial abrasions to
broken bones to serious head injuries
my heart goes out to those who are
witness to these events
my heart goes out to those who lost a
loved one i saw
one person on the ground i saw their
feet matt rood was at the parade with
his two young children i grabbed them
and pulled them back
towards the building and there's a bunch
of people
hunkered down telling to get down people
crying screaming because we didn't know
what was going on many in the parade
were dance cheer and band members from
local schools classes are canceled today
the district says it's bringing in extra
counselors for students and staff nancy
chen cbs news waukesha wisconsin
this morning waukesha police said four
of the victims are women between 52 and
79 years old the other victim an 81 year
old man